when I'm down in Antarctica and I see
our team working and I see our
scientists who are devoting their lives
to understanding the changing world
based on what's happening in Antarctica
my comfort is that there are generations
after me that will learn from the work
that we're doing there's quite a lot of
science that we do at Scott Base it's
quite diverse but I think one of the
most important pieces is how the the ice
is changing in Antarctica and how that's
going to impact the risk that we're not
just an rising sea level but the changes
to global climate this is an incredibly
pristine environment it's only really
been explored mostly in the last 50 or
60 years that will tell us so much about
what our future planet will look like
the hostility of the environment and the
proximity is very challenging you get
through that you get used to the cold a
little but there are certain things that
you do miss about being home for us
anyone that comes back to New Zealand
having been down on the ice would
normally roll around on the grass
because there is no grass there are no
trees there is no green I had a choice
between Perpetual Sun and perpetual
night very difficult question because in
the night of course you have the most
amazing
Aurora's that very few people get to see
but for me it is definitely the day to
be able to wake up at 3 a.m. 2 a.m. and
be bright sunlight as quite an unusual
thing but what you see and what you hear
in those hours is